welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
while he is away thanks for having me
David let's talk about some breaking
news from last night the Internal
Revenue Service this is according to the
New York Times the original reporting
was done by The Washington Post but
here's a quote from the New York Times
quote the IRS the Internal Revenue
Service has no choice but to honor
congressional requests for president
Trump's tax returns unless he invokes
executive privilege to protect them
according to a draft legal memo written
by agency staff members now this is
important because as you recall Steve
Newton's excuse for not turning over
Donald Trump's tax returns to the
committee in Congress that clearly has
the legal right to to obtain anyone's
tax returns for that matter Minuten
basically said that they did not have
the legislative purposes or legitimate
legislative purposes in fact here's the
quote saying quote the memo appears to
undercut the reasoning offered by
Treasury secretary Stephen the Newton's
Minuten who has refused to comply with
the Democrats requests because they lack
a quote legitimate legislative purpose
mr. minuchin said he made his decision
after consulting with lawyers from the
cesare Department the IRS and the
Justice Department now here's why this
matters he's claiming that he spoke to
lawyers at the IRS and here's a draft
that is surfaced a draft memo that has
surfaced that was written last fall
according to the Washington Post it was
never signed and never an official memo
and they are even they are they're
already giving a disclaimer saying that
this particular memo did not reach the
desk of Steve minuchin however if Steve
actually consulted with the IRS
attorneys it's very likely they would
have come to the same conclusion or it's
very likely that they had access to that
draft memo and so this claim that he
spoke that he's making this decision to
not turn over the president's tax
returns based on him consulting the IRS
attorney
doesn't really hold a lot of water right
it does become a he-said she-said kind
of gossipy type of thing but the bottom
line is this we're dealing with an
administration that has no regard for
checks and balances and not only are we
dealing with the president I make the
distinction of in an administration
because it's clear that President Trump
has no respect for checks and balances
he believes that he ought to be a
dictator that he has the right to
circumvent Congress and that he has the
authority and the ability to use his
bully pulpit to get his way that's one
thing but it becomes extreme it becomes
even more dangerous when you have
collaborators that are inside of all the
different agencies because that's truly
how a dictatorship is actually
implemented that's how authoritarianism
actually is brought to us it's not just
by one demagogic leader like Donald
Trump it's by those people throughout
the layers of administration who are
complicit like Steve the notion like
anyone who is bucking against these
these requests from Congress you have
the Attorney General you have others who
are ignoring subpoenas refusing to
testify before Congress I mean they're
literally looking at the checks and
balances system of our nation and
basically saying just to hell with it
right
there's no regard for it and that is
extremely dangerous but that is where we
have been for some time one of the
things I remember most and you probably
remember the same immediately after the
election of Donald Trump people went on
this this tirade this this tore rather
saying to not let this become the new
normal or this can't become the new
normal but the reality of it this is the
new normal and unless we figure out how
to adjust and to address this new normal
Donald Trump will continue to get away
with the things that he gets away with
and it does not help that we have
Democratic leadership Nancy Pelosi Chuck
Schumer who are timid on using the power
of impeachment right that is literally
their tool to put a person who is who
has no regard for the Constitution and
check Donald Trump has zero regard for
our norms our institutions but most
importantly the Constitution of the
United States and we have democratic
leadership who are afraid to actually do
what they have to do to protect our
democracy such as it is that is where
the danger really lies we have an
authoritarian style dictator at the top
one a big dictator at the top you have
people throughout the bureaucracies who
are complicit either with their silence
or their active collaborators with the
President and then you have an
opposition party who doesn't want to
play opposition or at least you have
leadership in the opposition party who
who simply do not want to fight back
this is a perfect recipe for a
dictatorship a full dictatorship for
authoritarianism and Donald Trump is
exactly the man to do it as you can
recall you may not recall but there is a
video of P of supporters of Donald Trump
and one of them literally said and if I
could find the clip I'll play it but but
you could google it
one of them literally said I never
thought that I would want a dictator but
if I do but if we do have a dictator I
want it to be Donald Trump so we have
like this we have all of the converging
forces necessary to usher in a
dictatorship and I'm not saying that in
in terms of hype scare tactics or ohai
hyperbole
we literally have the one system they
can place a check on the President of
the United States refusing to do so
while you have the president of the
United States his collaborators and
those who are simply complicit with
their silence ignoring the law
circumventing the law ignoring subpoenas
circumventing subpoenas and now we have
a document from the IRS that states that
that the president has to turn over his
tax returns to the Congress and we have
the leader of that department we have
Steve minuchin the secretary of the
Treasury whose
saying well I talked to them but we came
to the conclusion that Congress had no
legitimate legislative purpose in
requesting these documents from the
President of the United States
collaborators we have people who are
complicit either tacitly or directly and
we have an opposition party led by two
Democrats Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
who refuse to use their power to place a
check on this president who is clearly
out of control